bruce feldman joins us now from the
athletic he's got an incredible peace
out
on the technology giving josh allen and
joe burrow a big boost in their nfl
careers with jordan palmer who
bruce i keep thinking of him as carson's
brother but i think that he's come a
long way
so i it's been a long time since i've
seen you how are you
i'm doing great susie thanks for having
me yeah it's funny because
for almost everybody that's what jordan
palmer's been known as he was the
younger brother and he was the backup
i'm
sure people remember him you know when
real sports was around the bengals but
he's really emerged as
a pioneering quarterback coach in the
private qb space
and so i think what's fascinating just
to see what he's done
josh allen is the the thing that's been
kind of amazing about him is for so long
a lot of
coaches inside football believed
quarterbacks couldn't
get that that much more uh
accurate as they as they got older and
obviously josh allen had big accuracy
question marks coming out of wyoming
and what he and he and the bills and
certainly what
what uh jordan palmer have been able to
do by embracing this like
technology and and the biomechanics part
has been
pretty significant now now as people see
in the story
the way they talk about the improvement
in joe burrows
arm strength coming off this injury i
think is going to be really fascinating
to watch
funny we had peter king on the other day
and he was talking about the optimism
with the bills and and what's ahead for
them this season what exactly is jordan
doing that you saw in investigating this
piece that is
basically retraining these guys it is
and so
a lot of what he has done um is rooted
in biomechanics but it's also
if you think about like the marvel
movies in hollywood
they have the technology's been
obviously pretty mind-blowing with the
green screen technology and back not
that long ago
in order to have some of these cgi kind
of quality you would have
special suits that people would have to
wear or these kind of markers that were
dotted all over
human bodies well now uh palmer's really
connected with this company called
biometric
and they it's basically
if you throw your on around nine like
almost security style cameras it's not
like the cameras are that significant
but it's basically
like a quarter of a million dollars
worth of software
that processes it all in real time so
they're able to
get amazing feed feedback
into what is actually going on with the
body and then as palmer said it's it's
really also in the messaging he goes i
don't want to tell them i want them to
feel how this
is so in the case of joe burrow for
instance
uh he's a guy who when they train him
for the draft a year you know a year ago
he never
through they never clocked him at
throwing harder than 48.5 miles per hour
exit velocity
after he came through the rehab process
in his core and his lower body were
much stronger than it they've ever been
they tweaked some things and all of a
sudden
it kind of blew joe burrows mine when he
was like wait a minute i'm throwing 54
now
it was a dramatic difference and in the
case of a josh allen
i think it's really just being like
sharper and more accurate now on really
one or two
specific throws that they've spent a lot
of time this offseason
just getting his weight balance and
weight distribution just a little
cleaner than what it was so maybe he
doesn't the ball doesn't fail a little
bit on that particular throw
and it's that kind of maintenance that
they've done with the technology
and the biomechanics it's really it was
really fascinating to watch the whole
process from the inside out
how will they follow up as the
quarterbacks go back
to their teams their respective teams
and throughout the season
well this is one thing where these these
guys are you know they're like high
performance cars in a lot of ways they
know their bodies really well and
obviously palmer still connected
um you know to these guys because the
relationships but i think so much of it
is
in in josh allen and also the coaches
who work with them now they know exactly
what the tweaks are and uh and obviously
nothing is foolproof if injuries happen
and different things like that but i
think that what they're looking at is
the difference between the bills being a
super bowl team at this point
is maybe that one path on a third and 13
if he hits it and he's on the money it
can be a touchdown if not
if they're punting and maybe that that
could be the difference and so you know
talking to jordan palmer a lot about
that and he has spent so much time with
josh allen on this
he would like to see where he's come
from the guy who was at wyoming
you know who is a lot of people a lot of
questions about his
accuracy to where he is now where he
almost wanted mvp
it's um and it's not even that long it's
three years so
i think to see that all those steps i
think they feel like all right
you've got to keep working and keep
checking off boxes and now like i said
if they can
they feel more confident this in these
like one or two particular specific
throws
that they are they they've really tried
to re-engineer and tweak
um they've you know he feels like a guy
who completed 69 centers passes maybe in
the mid 70s this year
it's going to be fascinating to watch
him now on 3rd and 13th i'm going to
watch the games and look for those
passes and see because you're going to
have explained to us through this
article in the athletic of what to look
for and you're absolutely right
love to turn to college football and get
your thoughts bruce feldman
on this super conference that's emerging
with the sec in oklahoma and texas
yeah it's gone such a crazy turn
in the last week so yeah
in the short part of this so texas and
oh you
really were the the two programs that
drive a lot of the money and the
eyeballs when it relates to the tv
viewing audience for the big twelve
obviously those are the blue blood
programs there oklahoma's had a lot of
success
in recent years of lincoln riley texas
has had it's been really up and down but
not all that
uh uh this thing has been in the works
for a while
we've obviously heard a lot about it in
the last week
uh everything i'd heard from talking to
people around the big 12 is okay
you know espn and greg sankey have
really been in the middle of all this
they've been taking some financial
models and see that this is a
big big shift that is going to happen
at the top of the food chain in college
football to me what's really interesting
here is
greg thank you the sec commissioner was
on a small working group
uh with the com with the ad of notre
dame uh
another group of five commissioner craig
thompson from the mountain west
and then the fourth person is bob
bolesby the commissioner of the big 12.
they had spent a long time months and
months
secretly talking about how to expand the
playoff or what to do with the playoff
so while all those conversations were
going on all those meetings
greg sankey was basically not divulging
or you know keeping
bob goldsby the commissioner of the big
12 in the in the dark about
the moves he was plotting which were
basically
going to gut the big 12 and the big 12's
identity
as we all know it i mean that's kind of
it's really stealthy really
um really spicy stuff that was at the
core of all this
that that's going on right now and it's
there's a lot of more dominoes are going
to keep keep
toppling over from here by the way
that's your next book
fyi that's that's your next book what's
going to happen to notre dame
notre dame is going to is in a as usual
as in a strong financial position they
have a lot of leverage in terms of
you know the big ten decided it would it
felt like it was in its best interest
to expand notre dame would be a would be
a
big target uh the acc where
northern played this past year has a lot
of its sports are now competing in
i think that is that is something that
would be attracted the acc and if you're
the fcc you'd be like okay
this is a huge brand with a lot of
success and they've had a lot of good
football program
football teams of late i think they
would be attracted to the fcc and from
what i
was told notre dame was one of was
part of a financial model that greg
sankey espn had projected
in this process so you know
my guess is notre dame is going to sit
back and
see what exactly are is the best
you know they love the idea of being
unique in an independent
can they sustain it at the same level
going forward
if there are really two power
super power conferences let's say one is
obviously the sec
the other one is some version of the big
ten
you know after that i i don't know what
ufc
which has which it doesn't have as much
bargaining power as notre dame but still
has a lot
and i think you know one other thing
i've heard that
is significant but it's certainly it's
factors in for
notre dame is some of these other
conferences especially the big ten
the big ten wants to be in business with
aau
high academic accredited institutions
and notre dame is that so that just only
adds another chip in their pocket
but to see how they decide what's in
their best interest
that's that's like many of the many of
the tbd's but that's a big domino out
there
what do you think the end game will be
i think you're going to see a lot more
movement i also think you were going to
see a bunch of
schools that were previously aligned
with powerhouse programs in
in big conferences meaning if you're
a big 12 program and you are you know
that's a power five lead
you were in the same league and still
technically for now are with texas and
oklahoma
you know you were seen as as not a
mid-major program
i think what we're finding out and what
a lot of people
in greg senki's orbit already know is
if you are not one of those blue blood
big tv brand
programs um that's the differentiator so
for instance
you know while oklahoma state or texas
tech they have they have played
these other you know two elite programs
for years and they have leveraged some
of that because they get the tv money
but i think when it comes to the reality
when you study those tv numbers
and again that's where a lot of this
money comes from most of it
is they're probably closer
to aac programs to
tulsa and to i don't think
you know like cincinnati than they are
to texas and oklahoma or than they are
to ohio state
and alabama uh because
even you know like even in the games
oklahoma state plays oklahoma in their
big bedlam game
that gets a lot of attention if oklahoma
state is playing texas tech
or is playing baylor or is playing uh
kansas state it just does not have the
same appeal and that is a
harder sell for the tv people who are
going to be
you know footing the bill for this and
so that's the part where i think
you're going to see a bunch of these
programs get squeezed because they will
not be able to command the same price or
anywhere near the same price
that what you're going to see from the
sec from going to see from the big 10
and it's going to be survival of the
fittest and that's
gonna have a lot of unintended
consequences all the way down the line
from this too i think
well bruce feldman isn't that how it
always is i mean when you hear nick
saban talk about bryce young his
quarterback and about how he's going to
be making a million dollars
before he even basically steps on the
field and how hard it is going to be
with
the discrepancy of the other kids in his
team
it's all about money and we talked about
this yesterday
chris brockman and i were talking about
tradition and you know i love college
football i miss the traditions of it and
and i always found that to be one of the
most appealing things about it but
isn't this going to be bruce feldman
just
more of the rich get richer and the
bigger teams will just get more money
and more attention
how will this keep college football
competitive
i'm not sure it will in the same way
like what you said a minute ago the rich
get richer that is exactly what's going
to happen and i talked to
uh there was a tactile media days were
yesterday out in hollywood
and there's a lot of talk in the you
know the lobbies and in the hallways of
what exactly does this mean and one of
the administrators that
they uh at one of these programs had
made the case
with all these financial resources
and the windfall of money that is going
to just you know
blow through some of these heavyweight
programs or programs with these big
deals
that it's going to change and i was like
well how much money
are we you know you're talking about
coaching salaries
and so are we going to see coordinators
making four million dollars a year
at some programs now where that'll be
double what they what head coaches will
make in a lot of places i mean the
coaching salaries have have have
blown ups so dramatically in the last
10 years really even the last five years
that if you're talking about where the
tv money's going to go
i mean because already you're seeing you
know like the facilities
uh kind of war games of just how much
more money are they
are they throwing into this left and
right and yeah there's great resources
for student athletes on these campuses
but when you start talking about all the
other stuff that's coming with
it i don't know how you um
you know how a lot of the other ones are
they're not going to be able to compete
with that
because they're pushing the money so so
that the money is going to go
in such a hab than have not uh
space that it's gonna i don't think it's
gonna change the game to the point where
fans won't recognize it because at the
end of the day it's still gonna be
football
college football on the field but i
think what you're gonna have
is a lot of programs are going to be
marginalized
they will still have their own fans who
will still hopefully be passionate about
those
those teams but it's going to be such a
disparity between the have and have not
even more so than it's been and that's
saying a lot because it's not like
certainly it's not like the nfl or it's
not like other pro sports where there's
some
system of of
parity that's kind of built in whether
it's a draft or salary caps or different
things
we're not gonna you're gonna see such an
astronomical shift
if the money keeps going the way it does
and that's just gonna be a reality of it
i don't see any
anything that's gonna slow that down as
the tv dollars keep
keep piling in for certain programs and
they don't for others
bruce give me something hopeful for
college football before we wrap up today
i i need a little string to hold on to
as we're here in july because
boy it's a whole lot of uh it's a whole
lot of heavy right now in college
football
it is the one thing i would say and this
is from having been at
three different conference media days in
the last two weeks between the big 12
the big 10 and the pac-12
there's a lot of really really
impressive
20 21 22 year old people out there in
college football who are on these teams
and they have
a voice that they have never had before
in part because of social media some of
it's going to be related to nil
and i think there are it's not to say
that we did not have
a lot of really thoughtful um people who
are who know how to use their voice
years ago but i think there's just now
more opportunity i think they have come
up in a different way
and i was really blown away by some of
the people i've met
in how they present themselves
and what they want to do with their
platforms and how they want to reach
people and i think there's a lot of
really strong voices coming up
and i'm just talking really just in
terms of just the college football world
but i've had conversations with athletes
at i know one of the players at ucla and
i had a conversation with him about a
month
ago and he just kind of raved about some
of the female athletes in the ucla
athletic program
that he knows and that what they are
doing and what they're about and i think
there is a generation
of these athletes who
have their eyes open and i think those
are people who are really empowered
and i think those are things that are
really encouraging just beyond what's
going on on the field in the actual
competition
of of how they're going to help uh
influence things for some a lot of
positive
positivity bruce feldman from the
athletic and from fox sports thanks
again for your time we're going to seek
out that article and i think you all
should on joe burrow and
and on josh allen it's pretty great and
i'm really happy for all the success
that jordan palmer's had too
great speaking with you again great to
catch up great to catch up
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here